tonight Geena Davis brings the Exorcist
back to life on TV now anyone who saw
that terrifying movie 42 years ago will
absolutely never forget it and that
includes Gina just hearing the Exorcist
it was a big selling point for me
I had a big reaction to the movie I was
13 terrified in the new Fox TV series
there are a few Easter eggs that give a
head spinning nod to the original 1973
film this series takes place in a world
where that actually happened if there's
a shot of the staircase that he falls
down there's something inside my house a
demon that's trying to take my daughter
Gina plays a mom trying to protect your
family from some sinister forces to help
show and been researched exorcisms and
stuff online and they had nightmares
they couldn't sleep after that glad I
didn't do any research but reward this
series isn't a remake and the evil
spirit possessed more than just one
little girl when I signed on to do it I
said now I'm not just screaming the
whole time right I'm not just like I
will get other things to do well those
other things include Gina needing an
exorcism herself I'd want to be
possessed in an attractive way sometimes
in the movie at least they made position
look very on the trench possessed in a
glamorous I'm just saying the original
film was so incredibly terrifying give
me nightmares like no other film ever
now we asked Gina how graphic the TV
show will get and she said it's up to
the censors but they are gonna push it
as far as they can go watch it again